the Joe Rogan experience yeah and I was
really fascinated by another thing that
you were bringing up about working for
yourself that you feel in the future
whether it's fifty or hundred years from
now virtually everyone is going to be
working for themselves and I believe the
way you put it is that the information
age is gonna reverse the Industrial Age
yeah if you go back to hunter-gatherer
at times how we evolved we basically
work for ourselves we communicated and
cooperated within tribes but each hunter
each gatherer stood on their own and
then combine their resources with the
family unit but there was no boss
hierarchy honey hire you know you're
like the third middle manager down in
the farming age we became a little bit
more hierarchical as we had to run farms
but even those were still mostly family
farms it's industrial work with
factories that sort of created this
model of thousands of people working
together on one thing and having bosses
and schedules and times to show up the
reality is if you have to go I don't
care how rich you are I don't care
whether you're like a top Wall Street
banker if you have to go if somebody has
to tell you if somebody can tell you
when to be at work and what to wear and
how to behave you're not a free person
you're not actually rich so we're in
this model now where we think it's all
about employment and jobs and intrinsic
in that is that I have to work for
somebody else but the information age is
breaking that down so Ronald Coase is an
economist who has this Coast here I'm a
very famous theorem but it basically
just talks about why is a company the
size that it is why is a company one
person instead of ten people instead of
a hundred instead of a thousand and it
has to do with the internal transaction
costs which is the external transaction
costs let's say I want to do something
let's say I'm building a house and I
need someone to come in and provide the
lumber I'm a developer right do I want
that to be part of my company or do I
want that to be an external provider a
lot of it just depends on how hard it is
to do that transaction with someone
externally versus internally if it's too
hard to keep doing the contract every
time externally I'll bring that in-house
if it's easy to do externally and it's a
one-off kind of thing I'd rather keep it
out of the house well information
technology is making it easy and easier
to do these transactions externally it's
becoming much easier to communicate with
people gig economy I can send you small
amounts of money I can hire you through
an app I can rate you afterwards so
we're seeing an atomization of the firm
we're seeing the optimal size the firm's
shrinking it's most obvious in Silicon
Valley tons and tons of startups
constantly coming up and shaving off
little pieces of businesses from large
companies and turning them into huge
markets so what looked like the small
little vacation rental market on
Craigslist is now suddenly blown up into
Airbnb one example that's what an
example but what I think we're going to
see is whether it's 10 20 50 hundred
years from now high-quality work will be
available when I talk about driving an
uber we're talking about super high
quality work will be available in a gig
fashion where you'll wake up in the
morning your phone will buzz and you'll
have five different jobs from people who
work within the past or I've been
referred to you it's kind of how
Hollywood already works a little bit
with how they organize for a project you
decide where to take the project or not
the contract is right there in the spot
you get paid a certain amount you get
rated every day or every week you get
the might delivered and then when you're
done working you turn it off and you go
to Tahiti or wherever you want to spend
the next three months and I think the
smart people have already started
figuring out that the internet enables
this and they're starting to work more
and more remotely on their own schedule
on their own time and their own place
with their own friends in their own way
and that's actually how we are the most
productive so the information revolution
by making it easier to communicate
connect and cooperate is allowing us to
go back to working for ourselves and
that is my ultimate dream even when I
run a company and I have employees I
always tell those people hey I'm gonna
help you start your company when you're
ready because I think that's the highest
calling maybe not everybody will get
there but it would be fine if we were
even working a ten person company or 20
person company is way better than
working in a thousand person company
10,000 person company so this idea that
we're all factory like cogs in a machine
who are specialized and have to do
things by rote memorization or
instruction is going to go away and
we're going to go back to being small
groups of creative bands of individuals
setting out to do missions
and when those missions are done we
collect our money we get rated and then
we rest and reassess until we're ready
for the next sprint has there ever been
a study done on happiness and as it
regards to the size of companies not
that I'm aware but to me it's obvious
it's just an obvious the smaller the
company that happy you're gonna be the
more human your relations are the let's
give rules to operate under the more
flexible the more creative the more you
betray like a human just because you're
able to do multiple things yeah
[Applause]